I mean, in the beginning,
I just tried to talk myself
out of starting this
business because it really
doesn't make sense and in
that time of the world.
But the more I looked into climate change,
the more I understood
what a humongous problem
it is gonna be and I just had no choice.
About two years ago, nobody
was really interested.
They didn't think that it
would be a good business.
They didn't really see the money in it.
That's all changed so rapidly.
Everybody and their grandma
is calling themselves
a climate investor now,
which is fantastic.
I'm Henrietta Moon.
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of Carbo Culture.
And Carbo Culture is
removing atmospheric carbon
by turning biomass waste
into highly stable carbon
that remains stable for 1,000 years.
Most life on earth is
carbon and it's our fourth
most abundant element.
So it's not bad per se.
We just have it in the wrong
place in too much scale.
So we need to think of
the most elegant way
to actually bring down that
carbon from the atmosphere
and put it to use somewhere
where we can use it better.
This challenge is at the core
of Carbo Culture's mission.
The Helsinki-based startup
is focused on solving
the Earth's carbon problem while offering
a viable business model,
one that didn't even exist
at the beginning of her career.
I ended up in this crazy program
that was three-month intense program
at NASA Ames in California.
And that's where I met my
co-founder, Chris Carstens.
Back then, there was no price on carbon.
Emission trading was at
maybe five euros a ton.
And nobody was really
interested in pursuing that
as a business model.
We got started properly in 2017.
Today, the carbon market is
trading at over 10 times that
so times have changed.
Henrietta and her team
turned to nature itself
for inspiration on how to make this model
both effective and profitable.
Every year, nature draws
down carbon in the form
of photosynthesis into all our
biomass trees and plantations
and crops and everything you see.
But naturally, when that
biomass like the trees die,
they decompose and reenter
the atmosphere again.
And that's the natural carbon cycle.
At Carbo Culture, we
were trying to figure out
what is the most elegant
way to actually draw down
some of this carbon?
And instead of trying to
invent machines to take out
parts per million from
the atmosphere, we decided
that millions of years of nature
already knows how to do it.
So if you see a forest
today and in 500 years
it will essentially be the same size.
It's not gonna 10-X its
carbon removal capacity
or grow 10 times larger.
So we have these solar-powered
allies who use photosynthesis
and turn this carbon from
the atmosphere into biomass.
And we take that biomass such as nutshells
or peach pits or tree waste and we put it
into our patented reactor and we rapidly
take it to a ultra-high
heat where it carbonizes.
It doesn't decompose,
it's not eaten by microbes
or anything, and we can
store it safely in the soil.
By doing this, the carbon
that's almost pure carbon
remains stable from
1,000 years to let's say
maybe up to a million years.
Their first facility
resides in California,
which operates as a proof of concept
to demonstrate the process.
Basically we put biomass in there.
And we put them inside, we take them
to a ultra-high temperature,
about 1,000 degrees Celsius,
for a split second.
And in that time, the biomass carbonizes.
So it turns into a charcoal-like form.
You can mix it into compost
or put it in the soil
or use it for water
filtration or just bury it
in the ground, in a old
mineshaft or something.
Our technology is like on a
basic level at the same thing
as turning wood into a carbon is something
that everybody can do in
their home fireplace, right?
But now, if you wanna
make it like ultra, ultra,
ultra-efficient and actually
store the carbon away,
now it gets a little bit more difficult.
But the kinda principle is the same.
Right now, our batch takes about
two hours for a half a ton.
So we can do about 500 pounds
per hour let's say of biomass.
Now that they've mastered the concept,
it's really just a matter of scaling it up
by a factor of a million or so.
If we put a million of these
systems around the world,
we can actually use part of the
energy in the biomass itself
to power these systems.
And in this way, we're
helping the green transition
of the grid instead of hindering it.
This next scale-up at scale
would remove about 13,000 tons
of carbon dioxide annually.
So make a few thousand tons of biocarbon.
And that's a big step for us.
Though Carbo Culture has recently raised
$6.2 million in seed
financing, it will take
a lot more funding to get Carbo
Culture's vision to scale.
This Herculean effort
will require investments
from both public and private sectors.
And now that carbon
capture programs like this
are beginning to get traction,
Henrietta welcomes the competition.
If we look at the big picture,
we have a North Star mission
of a gigaton of removal,
which is one billion tons.
And it's a real insanity target.
It's definitely not easy.
It's light years away
from where we are today.
But for us, it means
that we also need to get
to that kind of a scale.
And there's probably gonna be
10 to 100 companies like us
in maybe a decade from now
that will be trying to get
to that gargantuan scale that is needed.